The intent of the visitor pattern,
is to vary the operation to be performed on the elements of a complex structure,
without changing the classes of the elements of the structure itself.
As an example use, imagine that you have an abstract syntax tree,
it might be in a compiler, useful for representing a program.
You might wish to walk the tree for various reasons.
For example, to generate code, to pretty print the, the program or
to do type checking.
This would result in three different visitors,
all walking the same composite data structure.
The motivation that the pattern addresses is to be able to
decouple the structural elements that is, the data structures.
>From the operations applies to them.
You think about this.
This means that there are two factors that control how you
are applying the operations.
One is the data structure itself which may have, may,
may have many different kinds of nodes.
And the other is the class of operations such as,
the code generation, pre-printing, and type checking